madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition canada le recueillement des
familles des victimes de la catastrophe
aérienne sur les lieux de l'accident
avant de se retrouver dans la prière
halifax lors d'une cérémonie religieuse
violente explosion gaz dans un immeuble
au cannet un homme en mettant fin à ses
jours a provoqué la déflagration de
morts 17 blessés la fête gâchée hier
soir par la pluie au grand stade de
johnny hallyday a promis qu'il
chanterait tout à l'heure quelle que
soit la météo
la déception de ses fans qui ne pourront
le voir ouverture du festival du film
américain à deauville avec le film
événement de steven spielberg il faut
sauver le soldat ryan
la violence du débarquement sur les
plages de normandie une histoire humaine
plus qu'une oeuvre historique
un devoir de mémoire nous aurons le
plaisir de retrouver à deauville steven
spielberg mais ouvrons ce journal avec
cette violente explosion dans un
immeuble au cannet ce matin le geste
désespéré d'un homme qui met fin à ses
jours en ouvrant le gaz est à l'origine
de la déflagration de morts 17 blessés
selon un dernier bilan est tout un
quartier traumatisés olivier théron et
yasmina farber il avait ouvert le gaz au
quatrième étage pour se suicider par
dépit amoureux selon la rumeur
à 9h10 ce matin l'immeuble a explosé cet
appartement de la cité des mirandoles
ont été soufflées le 5ème étage s'est
affaissé des pans de murs se sont
effondrés sur les habitants sur le
moment on a cru que c'était un tonnerre
où un tremblement de terre on sait pas
vraiment en soucier de ce qu'il y avait
à voir voir les vitres explosées mais
moi ce que j'ai fait j'avais ma nièce
avec moi mes parents en ce qu'on a fait
en est sorti j'ai crié j'ai récupéré six
là n'en fait cendres j'ai appelé mon
fils mon chéri qu'il avait dégagé
écrit hier pour commettre des délits
vraiment ma porte
d'autres ont eu moins de chance deux
personnes sont décédées dont l'homme qui
avait ouvert le gaz dix-huit personnes
sont blessées et trois grièvement
une cinquantaine de sapeurs pompiers
aidés de chiens ont sondé les gravats
toute la journée à la recherche de
survivants ou d'autres victimes
il y a eu également un travail conjoint
avec les services de police notamment
pour faire le point entre les locataires
des appartements détruits
elle est victime prise en charge est
effectivement tout le monde est retrouvé
et identifié donc a priori il est peu
probable que de nouvelles victimes se
trouvent encore impliqué ce matin il y
avait une quinzaine de jeunes enfants
dans cette maternelle en face de
l'immeuble
comme pour les proches des victimes il
faut au plus vite gérer le choc
émotionnel engendrés par l'explosion
je suis intervenu à la demande est
institutrice sur des chaînes de l'école
voisine
je pense que je vais revenir lundi pour
parler à l'ensemble des élèves ainsi que
leurs parents c'est à dire réunir
parents et enfants et que nous nous
parlons un peu de tout cela pour que la
presse se fasse du mieux possible pour
les pompiers la mission maintenance à
sécuriser l'immeuble des unités
spéciales sont venus soulever les dalles
étayer les couloirs afin qu'une ultime
fouilles soient entreprises dans les
décombres l'immeuble irrécupérable sera
ensuite rasé et ses habitants relogés
dans la cité sous le choc
la nuit ils s'assurent ne sera plus
comme les autres en fin de journée
aujourd'hui à genève une cérémonie
religieuse s'est déroulée à la
cathédrale saint-pierre de nombreux
diplomates des nations unies des
ambassadeurs et des anonymes se sont
joints pour partager le deuil des
familles des victimes des bougies
installé dans le choeur de l'église
saint bonnet
les 229 victimes de la catastrophe une
cérémonie oecuménique avec des
représentants des différents cultes au
canada maintenant trois jours après la
catastrophe aérienne la suisse air les
familles des victimes se retrouvent face
à la mer sur les lieux de l'accident par
petits groupes et à l'abri des regards
indiscrets
elle tente d'apprivoiser la douleur et
de commencer le long travail de deuil
dominique derda cet océan est une tombe
c'est pour cela qu'ils sont venus pour
se recueillir
deux jours après la catastrophe du vol
sens de la suisse air les familles les
proches des victimes ont fait le voyage
jusqu'en nouvelle écosse
le cauchemar pourtant est loin d'être
terminée si les sauveteurs ont vite
abandonné tout espoir de retrouver des
survivants
la mère porte encore au creux de ses
vagues décor en lambeaux qu'il faut
repêché avant qu'il ne s'échouent ou ne
sombre mais pour les enquêteurs
canadiens américains et suisses
l'important désormais est de retrouver
les boîtes noires de l'appareil afin de
tenter de découvrir les causes exactes
de l'accident
il a dû partir en vrille tout d'un coup
à mon avis c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est pour ça qu'il ne reste que des
petits morceaux
c'est comme si vous preniez une
citrouille et vous l'achetiez contre un
mur en béton et voilà le résultat sur
des dizaines de kilomètres l'infanterie
réquisitionnait ratissent les plages à
la recherche du moindre indice
aussi petit soit-il les experts veulent
recoller 1-1 tous les morceaux comme un
gigantesque puzzle ce que les boîtes
noires ne révélerons pas ils le
trouveront peut-être de cette façon
spontanément les riverains comme cette
vieille dame et sa fille se joignent à
l'opération
que ressentez-vous là sur cette plage
j'ai dit une prière pour là où je ne
fais pas où ils sont les sanaryens c'est
trop triste
dimanche à l'église ce sont les 60
habitants de peggy's cove qui uniront
leurs prières pour que jamais ne se
reproduise une telle catastrophe
avant elle la seule qui ait jamais hanté
leur mémoire c'était il y à bien des
années la noyade d'un vieux pêcheur nous
venons donc de le voir les recherches se
poursuivent au large des côtes du canada
maintenant au niveau de l' enquête
aucune certitude
il semble admis qu'il y ait eu en effet
de la fumée dans l'appareil mais rien
n'indique que cette fumée soit à
l'origine de la catastrophe
la compagnie swissair envisagent toutes
sortes d'hypothèses que nous explique
patrice pelé juste avant le crash
l'équipage du md-11 a fait savoir la
tour de contrôle que de la fumée avait
envahi le cockpit
alors aujourd'hui la swiss air
propriétaire de l'appareil a tenu à
présenter à la presse
l'exercice numéro 9 celui dit de la
fumée dans le cockpit un exercice en
forme de démonstration pour que personne
n'ignore la qualité des équipages et les
procédures qu'ils doivent impérativement
appliquer en cas de feu à bord après la
phase fictif de décollage de la fumée a
été injecté dans le cockpit
on a pu voir les deux hommes enfilez les
masques à oxygène et s'emparer de la
check list appropriée à la situation de
feu pendant que l'un tient le manche
l'autre égrène les consignes
l'électronique de bord et testé par
tranches la localisation du feu et son
extinction peut prendre de 15 à famille
derrière la fumée il y à aussi je pense
qu'on respire les résidus électrique
on respire les câbles brûlés et autres
produits toxiques à bord le feu à bord
responsable de l'accident n'est pour le
moment que l'une des hypothèses seul
examen des deux boîtes noires apportera
l'après réponse au pourquoi de ce drame
venons en maintenant à l'état de santé
de jean pierre chevènement état
stationnaire selon un dernier bulletin
nous y reviendrons ce matin lionel
jospin s'est rendu au val de grâce au
chevet de lys l'intérieur une visite de
près d'une heure lionel jospin s'est
longuement entretenu avec les plus de
jean pierre chevènement
pour sa part le président de la
république se tient régulièrement
informé et nous rejoignons maintenant
devant le val-de-grâce benoît duquesne
en fin d'après midi donc comme depuis
trois jours le bulletin de santé signée
par le médecin général de l'hôpital état
stationnaire que recouvre ce terme
absolument parle effectivement d' état
stationnaire ce soir mais dans le
communiqué lu tout à l'heure par le
médecin chef du val-de-grâce des termes
recueillis par alain du bas et bien vous
allez voir que les termes choisis sont
presque encore plus prudent qu'il ne
l'était déjà hier on insiste beaucoup
pour dire que eh bien nous sommes
toujours dans la phase critique et qu'il
est impossible de formuler un quelconque
pronostic fiable nous l'écoutons je
voulais le communiqué du 5 septembre
l'état de santé de monsieur jean pierre
chevènement reste stationnaire
nous sommes toujours dans la phase
critique et des soins de réanimation
intensive se poursuivre
il n'est pas encore possible formuler un
pronostic fiable
sauf élément nouveau le prochain
communiqué vous sera donné dans 48
heures
je vous remercie alors de précisions à
partir de ce communiqué d'abord en ce
qui concerne la priorité actuelle des
médecins et mais il s'agit de soigner
d'abord les conséquences rénales et
hépatiques du choc opératoire qui a subi
jean pierre chevènement serra ont
souffert il est sous dialyse et son foie
souffert également
il s'attache pour l'instant à soigner
cela et puis autre chose c'est que les
soins intensifs que doit subir jean
pierre chevènement actuellement sont des
soins très lourd et très douloureux et
comme son coma et réactif et bien on a
choisi de l'endormir artificiellement
c'est une procédure tout à fait normale
dans ce genre de cas mais la conséquence
de cette procédure c'est qu'on distingue
plus maintenant ce qui ressort du coma
et ce qui ressort de ce sommeil
artificiel
alors je vous ai tout à l'heure que les
médecins étaient encore plus prudent
qu'il ne l'était déjà hier
et bien tout simplement parce qu'ils
insistent beaucoup pour dire que
l'évolution de ce genre de cas est tout
à fait imprévisible
elle peut bien sûr s'améliorer tout le
monde le souhaite mais le peut
aussi se détériorer à n'importe quel
moment et donc il est impossible pour
eux actuellement de donner des signes
d'optimisme
merci duquenne le projet de
redéploiement entre police et
gendarmerie continue de susciter
l'inquiétude et le mécontentement des
élus locaux et de la population des
villes concernées ce projet prévoit
notamment la suppression de 94
commissariat dont celui de vendôme sur
place aujourd'hui les policiers
distribuer eux-mêmes des tracts la
grogne s'amplifie renoir sert philippe
ritaine jours de braderie et jour de
colère ont des policiers dont le
commissariat est menacée de disparition
en tenue civile tout l'après midi ils
l'ont répété dans la rue la question de
partir nous on est attaché à la villa on
connaît toute la population la
population nous connaît faut dire de mon
match considère que le sait c'est le
service public je veux dire le service
public
il faut quand même que ça reste dans une
ville comme une colombe en double où il
ya plus de vingt mille habitants
je pense qu'un commissariat à son
existence mais vendôme figure bel et
bien dans la liste des 94 petit
commissariat promis à la fermeture dans
toute la france ici les quarante trois
fonctionnaires de police pourrait donc
être remplacée par la gendarmerie
des gendarmes qui aujourd'hui ont pour
seul terrain d'action les communes
rurales autour de la ville sur semblait
commissaire ils seront remplacés par des
gendarmes qui seront trois fois moins
nombreux qui assureront une sécurité
beaucoup moins important puisque ne
pourront pas faire de 24 heures sur 24
j'ai l'intimé conviction que la
disparition d'un commissariat à vendôme
comme dans d'autres villes et bien
conduire et à partir d'un sous-effectif
constaté dans la gendarmerie conduirait
une dégradation évidente de la situation
que nous constatons aujourd'hui et dont
nous pouvons nous satisfaire et la
population se mobilise en l'espace de
deux mois les policiers revendique sept
mille quatre cents signatures pour le
maintien du commissariat en ville on la
voit la police
mais pas pas spécialement la gendarmerie
savait il n'en faut quand même
des policiers partout mais vendôme c'est
partie des villes où la délinquance est
peu importante
voilà pourquoi ces policiers pourraient
être redéployés vers des zones plus
sensibles
le sort de vendôme et des autres petits
commissariats ne devrait être connue
d'ici la mi-décembre la suite des
universités d'été avec à la grande motte
l'université d'été de démocratie et
libéral gilles de robien qui a
démissionné publiquement de cette
formation il ya quelques semaines
continue de s'opposer à tout accord ou
toute ambiguïté vis-à-vis du front
national et demande à la magnat de ne
pas faire de reset à l'extrême droite
carole comment yann streiff
comment construire même si l'ambiance se
veut détendu
la question essentielle reste encore
sans réponse candidat à la succession de
françois léotard françois bayrou devrait
hériter dans une dizaine de jours d'un
parti bien mal en point
c'est qu'après le choc des élections
régionales puis le départ d'alain
madelin et 2 cm l'udf le jeu désormais
sa survie que l'edf diminue c'est pas
une joie mais d'un malheur on veut faire
une chance c'est edf n'avait plus rien à
dire un discours appelé chewing gum qui
n'avait plus d'aider à l'est d'el ans
aujourd'hui elle réunit des personnes
qui sont d'accord sur l'essentiel
l'essentiel est d'abord la question des
alliances avec le front national
l'udf vient de clarifier la situation en
excluant charles millon et jean pierre
soisson de son groupe parlementaire et
réaffirmé son refus de toute ambiguïté
toute ambiguïté peut être mortelle
c'était la parole de françois bayrou je
fais mienne nous ne permettrons pas
c'est trop important nous permettront à
quiconque d'avoir une ambiguïté avec
d'extrêmes moi messi l'idf a clairement
défini sa stratégie
certains voudraient maintenant la voir
appliquées par l'ensemble de
l'opposition et dénonce ouvertement la
position choisie par le parti d'alain
madelin on ne peut pas à la fois tendre
la main à l'extrême droite au risque de
se faire
royer complètement et en même temps dire
qu'on fait partie d'une opposition
républicaine avec laquelle on fait une
liste commune par exemple aux élections
européennes les élections européennes de
juin prochain
c'est désormais l'échéance que se fixent
l'udf pour tenter de rebondir
l'avenir se devrait d'ailleurs être le
thème central du discours de clôture de
françois bayrou demain affiché son
optimisme
comme pour mieux oublier qu aucun des
problèmes de l'opposition n'est encore
vraiment réglé et puis au chapitre
économique cette information l'état
devrait réduire sa participation dans
arianespace
un désengagement qui permettra à
l'ensemble matra d'aérospatiale de
prendre le relais le centre national
d'études spatiales pourrait donc
diminuer sa part 2 32 à 20 % à calcutta
un an après la disparition de mère
teresa le match plein de douceur et de
recueillement de ces milliers de
personnes de toutes confessions unis
dans une même ferveur les plus pauvres
les plus nantis défilaient ensemble
aujourd'hui devant la tombe où reposent
celle qui a consacré sa vie aux
déshérités
isabelle steiss des roses du jasmin et
quelques orchidées blanches la fleur
préférée de mère teresa des bouquets
déposés sur une simple pierre tombale
avec pour épitaphe c'est nous qui lui
ressemble tant
aimez vous les uns les autres comme je
vous ai aimés autour de la sépulture de
la religieuse
il n'y avait pas assez de place pour
accueillir les milliers d'anonymes venus
se recueillir en ce jour anniversaire
loin des fastes qui avait entouré les
funérailles nationales il y a un an
c'est par de simples prière que tous à
l'image des missionnaires de l'ordre de
la charité ont rendu hommage à celle que
l'on appelait la sainte dépôt
elle nous a donné tellement de force et
d'énergie pour continuer à vivre dans
l'esprit qu'elle avait initiée c'est une
grande joie mais je suis aussi nostalgie
et elle nous manque à tous mais teresa
n'est plus mais son oeuvre continue dans
l'inde où ils sont 300 millions à vivre
sous le seuil de pauvreté vaste
aujourd'hui le souvenir mais aussi
l'héritage de 50 ans au service des
pauvres
quant à la canonisation de la religieuse
il faudra attendre cinq ans après la
mort pour entamer une procédure qui sera
longue mais dans le coeur des pauvres
mère teresa est déjà une sainte dans
plus d'une demi heure maintenant
devraient commencer au stade de france
le concert de johnny hallyday a annulé
hier en raison d'une pluie battante la
fête gâcher le spectacle qui tombe à
l'eau a provoqué la déception et même la
grogne de ses spectateurs qui ne sont
pas sûrs de pouvoir retrouver une place
louis carzou et régis mettez vous en
rêvez d'avoir
que l'inflation et les prix sont moins
élevés le son est en droit on ne peut
pas décoller sont les visages mouiller
et pas seulement par la pluie le geste
volontiers énervé pour les quelques 70
mille fans venus hier soir au stade de
france la déception était à la hauteur
de leur dévotion pour johnny immense
l'aurez compris je pense et jojo tu sais
on t'aime tu viens et on peut comprendre
mais c'est jean claude camus qui a pris
la décision et qui en a assumé
l'annoncent dès lors pas question pour
le producteur de lait c'est johnny
hallyday venir affronter le public sur
cette scène aux allures de radio là il a
vraiment avec nous étudier les
possibilités il a proposé et où il a
proposé de faire matinée soir et demain
ou matinée soirée dimanche mais pour des
problèmes de sécurité
c'était impossible de faire se croiser
cent soixante mille personnes parce 88
qui rendent grammy qui sort c'était
techniquement impossible il y aura donc
une date de remplacement vendredi
prochain en plus des places de pelouse
disponible ce soir et demain pour les
provinciaux et le comble hier soir s'est
produit sur une drôle de partitions
tandis que les spectateurs sont allés
sans le moindre incident de brèves
échauffourées ont vu s'affronter les
membres des différents services d'ordre
ouverture du festival du film américain
à deauville avec pour cette première
journée la projection du film événement
de steven spielberg il faut sauver le
soldat ryan stevens hulbert que nous
recevrons dans un instant mais d'abord
présentation de cette oeuvre magistrale
qui retrace de façon extrêmement crue la
violence du débarquement à travers
l'histoire très humaine de ces huit
soldats dont la mission impossible est
de sauver la vie d'un simple soldat
le soldat ryan superbe distribution avec
notamment tom hanks nicolas cornu
langlois émotions voici l'équipe du film
événement il faut sauver le soldat ryan
le réalisateur steven spielberg et les
acteurs tom hanks tom six morts edward
burns et c'est une tornade qui déferle
sur deauville
alanguie sous la pluie de cette fin
d'été sur ses plages tout proche a eu
lieu le 6 juin 1944
le débarquement des jeunes américains
portant sur la balle
un massacre et tonnerre de feu de
grenades de vue l'horreur une
reconstitution historique cruel et
minutieuse comme le prouvent ces images
d'archivés
tous
allez galop
les pédaliers font tomber au moment même
où les démarquer ailleurs le temps
lui-même ce qui préoccupe spielberg
c'est le comportement humain
un groupe d'hommes est chargée par
l'état major de retrouver le soldat ryan
parce que ses trois frères sont morts à
la guerre et c'est l'unique rescapée ça
rime à quoi de risquer la vie de huit
cas pour sauver celle d'un seul type à
penser à sa pauvre mère est oui j'ai une
mère mais aussi le sergent et de mère
je parie que même le capitaine à une
mère enfin peut-être pas le capitaine
qu'est ce qui se passe ça n'a aucun sens
est-ce que ce voyage était nécessaire de
demander les soldats américains
oui répond spielberg avec son film
n'oubliez jamais ce qui s'est passé là
en normandie
tout près de deauville
mais le film est déjà sorti aux états
unis on imagine l'émotion avec laquelle
les vétérans de la seconde guerre
mondiale ce qui ont pris place dans ces
péniches de débarquement et qui ont eu
la chance de survivre
ces vétérans donc ont revécu à travers
le film de spielberg cette période
chaotique
notre correspondant aux états unis
dominique derda les a rencontrés à 6000
kilomètres des plages de normandie sur
la côte du new jersey il est un vieil
homme dont la vie est à jamais marquée
par le souvenir de ce 6 juin 1944
ces images d'archivés sont certes
d'inestimables documents historiques
mais elles ne montrent ni la peur des
soldats avant l'assaut ni la violence
inouïe du carnage qui s'ensuivit léonard
lommel avait 24 ans quand les barges qui
transportait son bataillon du deuxième
renders accostèrent au pied de la pompe
quoique depuis cette date et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il ne s'est pas passé un
seul jour sans que je n'ai eu une pensée
pour ces gars formidables qui sont
tombées à mes côtés avec peter son
compagnon d'armes pour la cinquième fois
depuis juillet léonard va revoir le même
film sur grand écran et en stéréo
c'est leur mémoire que l'on projette
cette fois tout y y et le vacarme
insoutenable de la mitraille les corps
déchiquetés
mais aussi la rage de survivre et de
vaincre de ces jeunes combattants
volontaires venus d'autres atlantes
ce jour-là il y eu 2400 morts sur la
plage de marque
on les imagine ray sous le choc peter et
léonard après un tel spectacle
c'est au contraire une délivrance mon
fils a vu le film la semaine dernière il
a même appelé ma femme pour lui dire que
désormais il avait encore plus de
respect pour
jusque là on n'imaginait vraiment pas ce
que j'avais en dur et personne ne me
croit quand on racontait ce qu'on avait
vécu personnes pendant cinquante ans
quand ils iront voir le film ils vont
découvrir ce qu'on n'a jamais réussi à
leur faire comprendre ce que ce film
c'est la reconstitution la plus fidèle
de cette page de l'histoire que
quiconque ait jamais mise en scène alors
peut-être que maintenant on va nous
croient
depuis leur retour sur le sol américain
il on tue toutes les médailles
tous les honneurs
mais il aura fallu attendre un demi
siècle pour qu'enfin à hollywood un
réalisateur rendent à ces soldats n'ont
pas un hommage
mais leur vérité
nous rejoignons maintenant en direct de
deauville steven spielberg bonsoir vous
êtes donc en normandie pas très loin de
omaha beach l'une des cinq plages du
débarquement que de symboles on n'a pas
fini d'évoquer l'extrême violence de
votre film dont le point de départ
raconte précisément le carnage que fut
ce débarquement
apparemment vous n'avez voulu faire
aucune concession à la vérité et à la
réalité n'ont en effet pas dit mais que
dans la limite limite de mes moyens par
rapport aux objectifs financiers donnés
je voulais que ce joyau mot soit une
représentation très réaliste et juste du
sacrifice rendues par ces gamins il ya
54 ans pour aider avec le reste du monde
libre à préserver la civilisation
occidentale jusqu'ici au cinéma vous
pensez qu'on avait volé ou détourné
l'histoire de ces soldats du
débarquement vous vous sentiez un devoir
de mémoire
il ya eu beaucoup de films sur le jour j
de films auxquels je pense c'est le film
de ses actionnaires
au delà de la gloire et puis le jour le
plus long des albanais mais le film sur
la recherche que soldat d'une opération
de sauvetage a mené à ça mais après
quatre mois de ses frères au combat vous
avez filmé l'enfer le chaos avec la
terreur que l'on voit dans les yeux des
soldats
c'était rare ce que vous l'avez vous
même ressenti pendant le tournage il y a
bien entendu énormément non mais vous
vous sentez la terreur pendant le
tournage du film et veut dire que en
train de raconter une histoire et qu'on
est entourée de tellement artisans prix
qui sont là à vous aider à capturer
cette image
et présente à l'écran mais ça qui se
trouve sur le lieu d'un accident en fout
qu'ils se jouent leur de la victime
pourquoi les faits je me sentais un peu
comme un médecin plutôt qu'un jeu
monsieur pape est un homme là qui va
souffrir pendant le tournage du film
autant que les combattants de cette
guerre
votre souci de la vérité a été constant
je dirais presque obsessionnel au point
de faire appel à des figurants mutilé
vos acteurs sont passés par des camps
d'entraînement et même votre caméra
travail à la manière des reporter de
guerre ja oui oui tout à fait je suis un
petit peu obsessionnel et tout ce que je
fais quand le et m me permettent d'être
encore que c'est bien car je saute sur
l'occasion
on connaît votre patient pour les années
30 et 40 beaucoup de vos films et ont
puisé leur inspiration dans quoi ce film
sur la guerre s'est imposé pour vous
comme une nécessité
vous savez mon père a fait la deuxième
guerre mondiale moi quand j'étais gamin
j'entendais les histoires des exploits
de mon père en birmanie et puis tous les
camarades de régiment des anciens
combattants avaient également leur
propre histoire et depuis que je suis
gamin j'ai toujours été intrigué par
tous les événements de la deuxième
guerre mondiale pas simplement la maison
de l'horreur et puis j'ai vu tous les
traités comme des australiens nous
et c'est la marshall et puis j'ai essayé
de dire tout ce que je pouvais sur cette
période de l'histoire parce que depuis
que je suis gamin j'ai toujours été
obsédé par la deuxième guerre mondiale
il était inévitable qu'un jour j'aurai
l'occasion de raconter une histoire sur
la génération de mon père pour nous
français ce film prend une dimension
particulière quels sentiments souhaitez
vous que l'on ressente à la fin du film
de l'émotion de la compassion un
sentiment collectif d'être redevable à
ces soldats bien ce que je voudrais
surtout pas c'est que c'est quelque
chose qu'on va souvent avec les crimes
de guerre j'aimerais pas qu'il y ait un
sentiment de facilité c'est pas un film
sur la futilité de la guerre en fait
l'histoire raconte la recherche de
l'humanité comment trouver de l'humanité
au beau milieu du combat et je crois
qu'il faut se dire qu'on a tous fait
cela en sans elle les alliés après tout
c'est et les américains les britanniques
et canadiens les russes les français et
on avait tellement d'allier qui ensemble
ont mené à bien au retrait chenôve
hollande pour que sauver d'europe et il
ya eu tellement l'aide précieuse de la
résistance française points ne savait la
résistance française a transmis des
informations précieuses à mon sens avoir
sur les temps de ces plages du
débarquement est devez le jour jean la
résistance française a perturbé toutes
les activités ferroviaires et autres
calmants et donc c'est quelque chose que
vos compatriotes et et les miens ont
fait ensemble nous avons aidé mais c'est
vous que vous êtes libérés en quelques
mots qu'avez vous appris peut-être sur
vous même et sur la nature humaine à
travers ce film j'ai appris que la
nature humaine et bien ça ne coule pas
de source en quelque sorte nous sommes
tous vulnérables
c'était il ya très peu de choses que
nous puissions faire seul par contre on
peut faire tout aussi on travaille
ensemble avec la liste de schindler vous
aviez reverser les bénéfices au profit
de la fondation pour les justes avec ce
film je crois que vous allez créer un
musée du débarquement
pourquoi cette contribution pour moi
c'est quelque chose d'important choix
est important que les jeunes puissent
savoir pourquoi nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui puissent être reconnaissant
bien là ceux en qui ils foulaient la
gare ce qu'ils nous ont apporté un mois
que nous allons transmettre un à trois
enfants
on vient le musée sympa le nombre
d'endroits pour penser au passé et puis
on se tourner vers l'avenir nous sommes
tous un peu les enfants du soldat ryan
est-ce que vous pensez que notre
génération a mérité le sacrifice de ces
hommes
je pense notre génération a certainement
bénéficié du sacrifice de nos parents
d'ailleurs une remplaçante
nous ne pouvons faire que de notre non
je ne suis pas là pour critiquer juger
ce que nous avons fait au cours des ces
que chaque génération fait de son mieux
ses fans spielberg infiniment merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et très
bonne chance pour votre film live merci
à lille la grande braderie s'est
installé sous le soleil près de deux
millions de visiteurs sont attendus
cette fin de semaine un grand déballage
dans une ambiance de fête
marianne masse et dominique maes d'aller
qu'elle a il est 12h15 à l'envié fils
dont les prêts et c'est chaque année la
même question à quelle heure ça commence
officiel
c'était 15 heures pour tout le monde
mais certains font le pied de grue
depuis plus d'une semaine alors
forcément ça démange
la braderie de lille c'est un scénario
presque inchangé depuis moyen âge des
greniers qui se vide et qui en
remplissent d'autres demoiselles que
menez vous d'acheter z qui est très
ancien mais je ne sais pas exactement ce
que c'est alors qu'est ce que vous aimez
mieux à la braderie est les molières
fouille ils arrêtaient d'affaires dans
une affaire wheeler quelle affaire
ausssi hollywood qui put éviter de
fouiller dans les fripes les loques les
tas de trucs qui se troquent qui font
tic tac ou craque c'est ça la passion du
bras deux ils seront 2 millions ce
week-end pour les proches s'expriment
non non il est pas celle du tout
maintenant
l'as rome c'est la braderie c'est comme
un grand manège scènes de ménage et
tranches de vie daniel un jour a aidé
nous est arrivé à la maison avec marilyn
et moi je lui ai dit c'est elle moi donc
lille va décider de notre rupture de
notre rupture de neuvic en vue du futur
on aurait presque envie d'aller au
mariage du temps qu'elle aurait parié
vous manifestez votre colle contrôle
rien du tout à la limite
simplement je reviens rouler une pelle
utiles ou futiles tous les achats sont
bons et notamment l'incontournable
moules frites
il sent mangera 500 tonnes ce week end
attention à l'indigestion à bagatelle
superbe vitrine en plein air qui
accueille jusqu'à deux mâles les plus
belles voitures de toutes les époques
avec un modèle plutôt insolite qui a
pris la vedette et les a tout éclipsé
olivier caroff féerique de l'agneau ce
sont les plus rapides
les plus belles
et les plus chers depuis dix ans une
centaine d'automobiles classique triés
sur le volet vient se faire admirer à
bagatelle chromes rutilants peinture
impeccable mais cette année certains
propriétaires ont vite compris que cela
ne suffirait pas pour se faire remarquer
la star de l'exposition la voix si elle
est française et elle ressemble à tout
sauf à une voiture
c'était il ya 70 ans du fond de son
atelier parisien un ingénieur venait
d'inventer l'avion 120 en inventeur à
l'époque en 22 pensait avoir accouché de
la voiture la plus moderne qu'elle est
révolution automobile et et faire des
petits
et il pensait que tout l'automobile dans
le futur serait à l'image de son indica
il n'en a vendu que 30 mais il ne
s'était pas complètement trompé en 58 le
géant américain general motors se
reprend l'idée moteurs à turbine cockpit
de jets et pour faire encore plus vrai
on a supprimé le volant c'est avec cette
poignée qu'on dirige la voiture comme ça
c'est pour aller à droite pour aller à
gauche et pour freiner en tire en
arrière un prototype unique estimé à 2
millions de dollars la bagatelle de 12
millions de francs
évidemment ça fait cher pour une voiture
mais pour un avion de chasse
ces données c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres au canada le
recueillement des familles de victimes
de la catastrophe aérienne
elles se sont rendues sur les lieux de
l'accident avant de se retrouver dans la
prière à halifax
il ya la hante explosion au gaz dans un
immeuble au cannet un homme en mettant
fin à ses jours a provoqué la
déflagration de morts 17 blessés tout un
quartier traumatisés tout de suite la
météo nathalie rihouet de mater ou café
en direct de marseille puis à midi
polémique michèle cotta reçoit alahmad
là je vous retrouve de mal dès 13 heures
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente de fin de soirée sur france 2
autre